[Music]
[Applause]
I want to take a moment right now
to get real with you
I want to tell you about something that
happened to me this weekend and I want
to do it in a song
[Music]
[Music]
and I saw a white woman she was walking
up to me I knew just what was coming
baby it was too late I knew the next
words out of my mouth we're gonna make a
girl irate she asked me
excuse me where's the bread
that's what I said
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
freaking raggedy hacks
[Music]
don't work here
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I was picking out a TV at the Uptown
Best Buy store I was looking at Bust
Around sound baby but I found so much
more a man so white he almost blowed
stopped me with this card he said give
me the floor model gonna wrap it up
sweetheart
here I share my little trick
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'll take a vanilla latte ma'am what
are you doing ordering a coffee aren't
you a barista no this isn't even a
Starbucks oh my God I'm so sorry please
don't be mad I'm one of the good ones
can I still get that coffee
no
no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
like I was here baby
but people also could destroy yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign